Priya Singh: Today’s focus: migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Noah Williams: Any blockers from last time?
Samira López: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Samira López: Let’s not block on migration to PostgreSQL 15; ship a thin slice.
Noah Williams: I propose we split migration to PostgreSQL 15 into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: Quick update on the scope on migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Priya Singh: Coordinate with SRE for rollout on migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Priya Singh: From QA perspective, We need to timebox the spike.
Avery Kim: Edge cases around auth and retries on migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Priya Singh: Action: book design review.
Riley Chen: From design side, We might need a migration.
Riley Chen: We should add a feature flag on migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on migration to PostgreSQL 15; ship a thin slice.
Jordan Patel: Risk: data migration for migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Noah Williams: Risk: data migration for migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Samira López: Action: set up dashboards.
Jordan Patel: Action: set up dashboards.
Priya Singh: From design side, We can chunk work behind a ticket.
Riley Chen: Action: create test plan.
Avery Kim: From QA perspective, Coordinate with SRE for rollout.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on migration to PostgreSQL 15; ship a thin slice.
Riley Chen: Risk: scope creep for migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Jordan Patel: I think we split migration to PostgreSQL 15 into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: Any risks we’re missing? on migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Jordan Patel: Action: write migration.
Riley Chen: Action: create test plan.
Jordan Patel: Any risks we’re missing? on migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Samira López: I think we split migration to PostgreSQL 15 into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: My take is we split migration to PostgreSQL 15 into two subtasks.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on migration to PostgreSQL 15; start with a spike.
Noah Williams: Infra-wise, We can chunk work behind a ticket.
Jordan Patel: Risk: scope creep for migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Jordan Patel: Edge cases around auth and retries on migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Avery Kim: Risk: flaky tests for migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Samira López: Risk: accessibility gaps for migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Samira López: Let’s keep this within this sprint on migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Priya Singh: Risk: accessibility gaps for migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Riley Chen: Let’s capture action items clearly on migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Riley Chen: Risk: flaky tests for migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Riley Chen: From design side, We need to align with capacity.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on migration to PostgreSQL 15; ship a thin slice.
Noah Williams: Quick update on the scope on migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Avery Kim: I propose we split migration to PostgreSQL 15 into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: From design side, Performance baseline needs to be recorded.
Samira López: Let’s not block on migration to PostgreSQL 15; start with a spike.
Riley Chen: Action: set up dashboards.
Avery Kim: My take is we split migration to PostgreSQL 15 into two subtasks.
Samira López: Action: write migration.
Priya Singh: UX needs a final pass on migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Avery Kim: Risk: flaky tests for migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Noah Williams: Let’s capture action items clearly on migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Riley Chen: Observability dashboards for errors on migration to PostgreSQL 15.
Avery Kim: Okay, who can take ownership?
Priya Singh: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Samira López: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.